- [Voiceover] You're
playing with and against
all the different people in the club.
And you learn to appreciate
them because of that.
It's just a little family.
It's an odd little sport and it's unique.
It's easy to play, but hard to master.
(dramatic music)
- [Voiceover] Come on.
- That one's short, oh.
- [Voiceover] All right, three.
- Cadieux Cafe is the only
place where there's authentic
Belgian feather bowling
in the United States.
It's a bowling game,
that uses wooden discs
that you throw at a
feather at the opposite end
of the lane to try and
get close to the feather.
It's similar to bocce
or horseshoes in that
it's a target sport that way.
The unique thing about this
one is that the lane is convex
and the ball tends to
move in odd directions.
You can score points by
being the closest with your
color ball, closest to the
feather of the same color.
Yellow touching, not touching the yellow.
Some people are really good right away,
other people, they've been
on the club for a while
and I still don't know what
they're gonna do out there
when they throw the ball.
- [Voiceover] Oh, it was a
point and then it wasn't.
It's down to one.
- Cadieux Cafe today is a bar
and restaurant in Detroit.
This neighborhood was a largely
Belgian-American
neighborhood at one point.
When the club started in
1933, this was a place
for recent immigrants
after the war to come over
and have a little taste of home.
More popular than it's been,
I mean our average attendance
for bowling every week has gone up
the last three, four years.
There’s a good group of guys here.
They’re from all over, all walks of life.
You sit there every week with them.
You bowl with them, you bowl against them,
and it's just a good time.